hello
and welcome to the webinar today
entitled targeted degradation
of the enhancer lysine acetyl
transversus
cbp and p300
my name is alexis krauss of levers and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
i'd like to thank everyone for attending
today and i'm happy to welcome our
featured speakers for today
dr christopher ott and dr tim geiger
this webinar is supported by biotechne
biotechny brings together the
prestigious life science research brands
of r d
systems novus biologicals tocres
bioscience
protein simple advanced cell diagnostics
and exosome diagnostics
to provide the scientific research
community with a comprehensive and
world-class product portfolio of
reagents
media extracellular matrices small
molecules
assays and instruments
before moving into the talks by our
featured speakers i have just a few
housekeeping items to address
throughout the webinar we invite you to
submit any questions you have for our
presenters using the ask a question box
located on the left side of your screen
these questions will be asked to the
presenters directly following the
presentation
in addition right below the ask a
question box you will see a tab called
handouts in that tab you'll find extra
content that relates to today's webinar
and now i would like to introduce our
speakers for today
dr christopher ott and dr tim geiger
dr tim geiger is a molecular and
cellular biologist
who has enjoyed a varied career from his
postdoctoral work
developing in vitro transcriptional
recruitment models
to overseeing research teams in
diagnostics and pharmaceutical
analytical development
to business development and high
throughput immune sequencing
he also guest lectures at uc san diego
on omics and translational medicine
he has an early adopter from the simple
western technology before joining
biotechne
where as a field applications manager he
continues to focus on the simple western
product line
dr christopher ott is a chemical
biologist at the center for cancer
research at massachusetts general
hospital
and harvard medical school the principal
focus of his research
is to determine mechanisms of
malfunctioning gene regulation in cancer
and to develop therapeutic strategies
to modulate gene regulatory factors in
tumors
his team is developing early stage
chemical probes
and prototype drugs directed at
modulating critical gene regulatory
factors
including the first chemical degraders
of the enhancer
acetyl transversus cbp and p300
i will now turn it over to dr geiger for
the presentation for today
welcome sir
all right well thank you for that
introduction i'm going to give you a
quick introduction to simple western
before we get into
chris's presentation
okay so what exactly is simple western
if you're joining this webinar you
probably already have a sense on what
simple western is
fundamentally we're a replacement for
western black right
but simple western is really more akin
to a capillary electrophoresis
instrument
or protein separation upstream of
detection by an immunoassay
specifically an indirect immunoacademic
elisa
and we are as a company our dominant
players in templar electrophoresis with
our instruments supporting
biological development and testing
throughout the biopharmaceutical
industry
so we sell the ice family of instruments
with our flagship instrument being this
one here
the maurice which on the left here which
does both size
and charge-based separation for
analytical characterization of
pharmaceuticals and this is
data that is well accepted by the fda
and other regulatory agencies in this
space
biotechnic is also a leader in amino
assays we have a large class
catalog of proteins and antibodies
through our novus and rnt systems brands
anybody in the lives of space knows are
quantikine kits they're
considered gold standards and they
validate their lives of space
and we sell limits limits reagents and
then we have this
ella platform which is an automated
bench topolizer
so surely these two technologies that
merge to create simple western
uh ironically considering the name
simple western the one thing that we are
fundamentally not
is a western blot and i will explain
that so we are set we're
next generation for that technology but
we're definitely not a westbound i'll
explain that in the next slide
okay um so i'm going to show you a video
this is of the jess but the west is
fundamentally the same
look and feel so there's fundamentally
two
big leaps forward with simple western um
and that is
relative to western bot you get much
faster results
and you get quantitative reproducible
data
an experiment on this is fairly easy to
set up once you're familiar with it
there's two things that you're loading
into the system one is this cap light
cartridge as you see on the top here
this is a 25 cap cartridge you also have
a 13. so you have enough room here for
24 samples plus your molecular weight
ladder
and then we have this plate
um so you're just gonna load your
samples and then all your immunoassay
reagents so basically your antibodies
and solutions
to the blade it's already preloaded with
separation reagents
and then once you've loaded the plate
set up the plate then you just load it
into the instrument plus the cartridges
close the door and hit start
the system is going to start
by preparing the capillaries for the
protein separation phase
and you know as i mentioned before the
proteins are separated akin to
size-based capillary electric braces or
ces yes
and like that system simple western uses
a linear polymer
separation matrix so um we're also using
a discontinuous
separation setup with a stacking matrix
here
all right so the next step then is
sample loading and
um i mentioned that simple western has a
lot lower
it's a much more
precise instrument less variation than
you would then you would deal with the
classic question bot
so there's a there's a few different
things in classic western bot that
kind of encroach error into the assay
and pipetting era is definitely one of
those issues because you're loading your
sample directly into the gel
we've minimized that source of error
because your sample is loaded into the
well
in excess and then the instrument
controls how much of that sample
actually gets loaded into the capillary
and it's pretty little it's about
less than 100 nanoliters of sample that
actually gets loaded in
all right so now your capillaries are
all loaded
now they're going to move over into the
running buffer voltage will be applied
and the proteins are going to be
separated by size
okay so this step right here this is why
we are not a western blot
by definition a western blot involves
the blotting of proteins
onto a membrane and that is again a
major source of variation in the classic
western blot
so we've eliminated that step by photo
cross linking our proteins onto the
capillary surface
now we can do the entire acid within
that capillary
so now let your proteins are
photocrosslinked the system can flush
out all the separation reagents
come in with a blocking buffer primary
antibody which is going to come through
in a sec
there's your primary antibody and then
that will be followed up by a secondary
antibody
and detection
all right with the west you're going to
use chemoluminescence for detection
with the jest you have chemoluminescence
but you also have two fluorescence
channels
you have a protein normalization channel
for total protein
normalization so so basically you have
four channels of detection with the jazz
and then we also have this new reagent
the replex reagent
that you've hopefully heard about and
this can remove the antibodies from the
first probing
so that you can come in and do a second
probing on the same capillary
so you're increasing your multiplexing
even further with that
so when you consider that each capillary
is independent
and loaded from separate wells you can
make highly complex experiments
by you know doing different reagents of
different capillaries
so in the end you know you can make a
pretty highly complex a highly modular
highly multiplex
assay if you're trying to address very
you know complex
scientific questions um
but remember you don't have to do that
right um
if your current western bots are working
for you um the system still is
advantageous i mean if you're just
looking to accelerate your science
this system gives you results in as
little as three hours
okay so here is the the whole simple
western
family of products i've already
introduced the wes and jess
again these both load up to 25 cap
cartridges so you can
enroll about 24 samples plus your
molecular weight ladder
and then we also have these three large
format systems i'm just showing two here
but these all load up to 88 of your
samples
and it's run all at once but it's done
over eight cycles
and these are our sally sue our nanopro
1000 and then our pegasu instruments and
the sally sue does size separation
nanopro does charge and peggy sue does
charge
or size base separation it does both
um and and again in terms of advantages
the system is very fast results in as
little as three hours
and it's fully automated right so you
can go off and do other science while
you're waiting for this
it's nimble you can have um very simple
experiments if that's what you're
looking for but you can do very complex
experiments as well on it
and something i haven't highlighted
before is the low sample volume again
i consider this something that
accelerates your science because
you spend less time um you know
producing enough sample necessary to be
able to do
larger experiments because you can work
with these small volumes
um but again you know speed is nothing
if you cannot generate
good quality data and our automation
gives you the precise reproducible data
you're looking for
and then our software which is really
user friendly
makes it easier to report out
quantitative data with our system
um you know in the title of the site
science is only as precise as its
weakest linked
this is why we at protein simple like
working closely with all of our
uh techniques and brands
um biotechnology produces a lot of
different reagents and scientific
solutions
to available for clients and then
provide them tools can then
date accurate and full data with
reagents
uh and this is one nice example this is
work we did you know working very
closely with our r d systems group to
develop the sars cova ii
geological module and i'm not going to
go into details about this module but i
i'm just using really to highlight the
capabilities of the system with a
well-developed assay
so what you're looking at in this left
graph this is an electro ferrogram
um we're doing a titration series
of these samples and you can see this is
our stars cova2
ladder and if you can't see the labels
it's rb2 nuke the
s2 and s1 subunits and then folding
spike protein
so the x-axis is molecular weight and
then on the right on the y-axis is
chemoluminescence
and this was a dilution series done in
duplicate so each one of these traces
here you can see it's paired up
and what's striking about it is if you
look at the graph on the right now this
is that same data reported out
and in this case you've got human
luminescence which is area under the
curve on the left
on the x other side of the y axis and
then
dilution on the x axis and remember
these are duplicates
you can barely discern the fact that
there are two points at each one of
these titration points on these curves
for these five proteins
really the only one where i'd say you
start to see the points significantly
diverge is this lowest data point here
on the far right so i'd probably argue
that that
last data point is falling out of the
quantitative range of the assay
but certainly uh you know disclosing
that single data point you're looking at
um you know at least three logs of
linearity in this experiment here
it's really really nice data
uh similarly we've been working closely
with our tacrist brand
and they generate small molecules and
peptides aid in life science research
one of the platforms they've licensed is
the protacs and these are going to be
highlighted in dr opt's talk today these
are bifunctional small molecules that
recruit the
e3 ligase to your target of interest
through
this linker region here by recruiting
that e3 ligase
this leads to poly ubiquitination of
your target and then
subsequent degradation through the
jupiter ubiquitin degradation pathway
um yeah just
you know a general statement it's hard
to make breakthrough
biological discoveries if you're limited
by the precision of the tools you're
using
to study those biological changes so
um again this is why simple western is a
really good complement to things like
these protacs
all right one last slide i just wanted
to quickly
call out a milestone that we at protein
simple are really proud of
simple western has just crossed the
thousand publication
threshold uh and we're well represented
as you can see on the right here on some
really high
impact journals so it's just really
great
to see how well adopted uh simple
western has been humble over the last
few years
all right um well thank you then and i'm
going to go ahead and pass it on to
chris
thanks tim for the opportunity to
present some recent work on behalf of my
research group
which is specifically focused on a tool
compound that we've recently described
uh one of these protac molecules that
targets
two important acetyl transferases cbp
and p300
this work comes out of my laboratory for
chemical epigenomics which is
based within the center for cancer
research at massachusetts general
hospital and harvard medical school and
you can
read more about our work and interests
that are at our website
lab.org
so any discussion of our approaches to
chemical epigenomics as it relates to
cancer biology needs to
begin by framing how we think of the
epigenome and its
impact on the hallmarks of cancer cells
um
conrad waddington first proposed a
conceptual framework of the epigenome
the
deterministic cellular signaling that
occurs on top
of our genome as a series of hills and
valleys
undercurrent undergirded by genetic guy
wires
that enforce a particular cell state as
a cell becomes more differentiated and
in cancer genetic mutations disrupt this
skywire scaffold in turn leading to
alterations and the
height and depth of these peaks and
valleys
which for the differentiated cells the
potential or the ability to
sample alternative cell states that can
eventually facilitate the outgrowth
of a malignant clone characterized by
hyper proliferation
and resistance to apoptotic cell death
the hallmarks of cancer
and while there are many signaling
platforms that make up the epigenome
the most proximal to genes themselves is
chromine
the nuclear structures that fold and
organize the genome and
both highly compact heterochromatic or
more
loose or accessible euchromatic
structures
and there are a huge number of chemical
features that make up chromatin
including post-translational marks of
histones
transcription factors that bind directly
to dna the
chromatin associated factors that can
both
modify nucleosomes modify transcription
factors with post-translational marks
and move nucleosomes out of the way of
specific regulatory elements of the
genome
um a principal interest to my group
are uh enhancer elements shown up here
in the the left
which are emblematic of active chromatin
and mediate the
transcriptional activation of genes that
have uh restricted or
more cell type specific expression
um enhancer activity is primarily
mediated through the direct
dna binding activity of transcription
factors and we think of transcription
factors as sort of the integrators of
genetic to epigenetic signals they bind
to dna in a dna specific manner through
their dna binding domain
and so they require a specific a
specific genetic input for their
activity and then they signal to other
functional domains the components of the
epigenome to induce macromolecular
formation
ultimately chromosomal looping
recruitment of rna polymerases
to activate gene expression and
polymerase elongation and ultimately
rna production there are a lot of
features of enhancers characteristics of
enhancers they can be very distal from
the promoters that they regulate
um they're hypersensitive to nucleases
they contain very specific histone
modifications
including lysine methylation and lysine
acetylation
the first descriptions of enhancer
activity by
walter shafter and his group way back in
the early 80s
revealed two distinct classes of
enhancers enhancers like the
viral sb40 enhancer that seemed to be
ubiquitous and active across
many different cell types and then
enhancers like the immunoglobulin
enhancer which had very specific
restricted cell type activity here
specifically lighting up a reporter gene
specifically in myeloma cells and not in
hela cells and
larger efforts um more modern efforts
like the roadmap
genomic consortium the encode consortium
have basically proven this principle and
that there are
classes of enhancers that are ubiquitous
across tissues and that there is a
subset of enhancers across tissues that
are very cell type specific and these
are the principal mediators of cell type
specific gene expression
um presciently in their 1983 cell paper
shafter and his colleagues suppose that
advert enhancer activity could actually
lead to diseases such as cancer
and you know recent research has
dramatically expanded our
understanding into really how
significantly enhancers
can contribute to cancer
many different types of cancer and so my
group
at mgh is focused on developing tools
and insights to test the hypothesis
that direct targeting of enhancers may
be a rational approach for cancer
therapy
this involves developing screening
assays new ligands and new chemistry to
target the transcription and chromatin
factors that
establish and maintain enhancers um and
also utilizing high-resolution
genome-wide profiling technologies to
discover response and resistant
biomarkers to these
uh to this new chemistry and mechanistic
insights into the activity of
synthetic enhancer modulators whether
they be small molecules or slightly more
larger molecules such as the one i'll
describe in this
presentation and
one aspect to enhancers or
characteristic of enhancers that we are
particularly focused on
is their high level of lysine
acetylation
lysine side chains throughout enhancer
structures can be highly acetylated
both on histones transcription factors
other chromatin regulators
and they're acetylated to the activity
of hat or cat lysine acetyl transferase
enzymes
and this acetylation is highly dynamic
and so while
the cat enzymes are the writers of this
acetyl mark hdacs or histone
diacetylases
remove these post-translational marks or
the erasers
and integral to affecting this
chemical signaling uh are proteins that
contain a specialized protein module
called a bromodamane
which is a specific reader of lysine
acetylation
proteins with bromidamines read
combinations of acetylytes at enhancers
which affect signaling
enhancers through either uh subsequent
protein protein interactions or
enzymatic activity well bromidomains are
these specialized acetyl lysine binding
modules there are 46 proteins in the
human genome that contain a
bromodomine some contain more than one
bromine
um their structure is very unique
they're a left-handed bundle of four
alpha helices and
they is binding to acetylacing through
it through
a conserved asparagine that is in the
middle of the pocket there
um while this asparagine mediated
recognition of acetyl lysine is highly
conserved it's the
the flanking residues of bromonomias
that are actually um
quite distinct from one another another
and confers specificity to binding
specific
acetylated lysines on on different uh
different epitopes um one of the
uh bromide main factors is probably most
well studied and one that i was very
interested in during my post doctoral
studies was this protein
bromine containing protein called brd4
which is very highly active in enhancer
elements
it's an epigenetic bookmark if you will
of active genes remaining on chromatin
through uh mitosis and
uh functions by recruiting the ptfe
complex to active promoters and
able to activate uh elongation from of
rna polymerase ii
um during my post-doc over at the
dana-farber cancer institute in jay
bradner's lab there was a chemist in our
group jun qi who
developed the first synthetic small
molecule ligand that's specifically
bound to uh the bromodomains of brd4 and
closely related members of the
this bromodomain family called the the
bet family of the bromodomain and
extraterminal
uh family of proteins and this compound
has remarkable activity and lots of
people have been studying this molecule
in lots of different
facets of chromosome biology and cancer
biology
and one piece of data that i was
particularly fascinated with was this
piece of data generated
um in our lab and in collaboration with
constantine missionas lab where
they found that um uh treatment with uh
jq1 of a
myeloma cell line like the potent cell
death and specific depletion of brd4
specifically on the immunoglobulin
enhancer those
that same enhancer that walter shafner
first described as being the first
cellular enhancer and specific to
b lymphoid the b lymphoid lineage in
this cell line
this enhancer is actually oncogenic it's
translocated to the mic locus
so it actually forces high expression of
the mic oncogene and through
displacement of brd4 with this small
molecule from chromatin you release
brd4 from this oncogenic enhancer
leading to down regulation of the
mechanism
and so um i followed up on this work in
looking in other contexts of b
lymphoid malignancies with david
weinstock and his group
studying b-cell acute lymphoblastic um
where jq1
this bromidamine binding ligand is very
highly active and also in chronic
lymphocytic leukemia with
jennifer brown and her lab where the
molecule is quite active both in in
vitro models and
individual models of the disease
but one aspect of bromodomain ligands
is that they just target the bromidamine
and in some cases this can be
lead to very potent displacement of the
protein from the acetyleases that they
recognize
um but a lot of proteins that contain
bromide domains actually have a lot of
other functional domains which
um are not actually inactivated uh with
bromonomial ligands and so
um uh two of my friends who were
postdocs with me in in
in j bradner's lab over at the farber
came up with this idea where they could
potentially
um link jq1 to a ligand that binds to an
e3 ligase in this case uh
solidimide which binds to the e3 ligase
cerebellum
which then would potentially hijack
cerebellum to induce protein degradation
through the ubiquitination of
in this case brd4 and this worked for
mark will be well
remarkably well um uh they described the
alternate complex formation
with the with this molecule this linked
molecule
um it's called dbet one with this rather
modest linkage
and uh you know very quickly could
observe degradation
of and loss of brd4 protein um with
treatment of this molecule and so
this concept actually extends um this
concept that was really pioneered by
craig cruz and ray de shades this
idea of proteolysis targeting chimeras
in which
you have a synthetic molecule that
basically brings in the close proximity
of protein of interest
and an e3 ubiquinolidase complex in
order to selectively degrade
through the ubiquitin and proteasome
system of protein of interest and so
there's been
a lot of work in the in the past few
years describing the system
and different compounds that that can
degrade different proteins of interest
and
hijack different e3 ligases hijacking
different
e3 like depending on the ligand's use
and so when i started my lab a few years
ago here at mgh
we decided to try this concept
to degrade several proteins that had not
been degraded before by this mechanism
in particular these two um lysine acetyl
transferases p300 and cpt
for which a lot had been studied and a
lot of ligand development had been
done but had had not really been
effectively been
degraded by this type of chemistry
before and
we were particularly interested in these
proteins because they have
um they're chromatin associated proteins
and enhancer associated proteins that
have a lot of different functional
domains to them
so they they they're part of a unique
class of proteins that have both a
acetyl lysine reader domain through the
bromide domain but also a lysine
acetyl-transferase domain
and a lot of different aspects of the
biology of these proteins has been
studied they're very highly homologous
so at the domain level they're
you know typically over 90 percent
conserved they dynamically acceleate
over 21 000 lysines in the proteome on
over 5000 different protein substrates
and this exemplified in tuna chowdery is
excellent paper and cell just a few
years ago where they
really profiled the dynamic acetyl
acetylum of cbp and p300
these factors are required for enhancer
media transcription and
there have been a lot of there has been
a lot of ligand developments for
the different domains of this protein of
these proteins in particular the
bromodomain
and the lysine acetyltransferase domain
and these molecules have been
developed to be quite potent but they
have differing effects on the protein
and neither
inhibitors of the the cat domain or the
bromelain can completely ablate the
activity
of the protein interestingly
when you combine these molecules in cell
culture and treat cells with
molecules that target the bromidamine
and target the acetyl transferase domain
they can have quite potent synergistic
activity in cancer cell line models here
described by phil cole and his group in
a paper a couple of years ago in a
prostate cancer cell and it seems like
when you when you inhibit both the
catholine and the bromidamine
you have a sort of an accelerated or um
a highly effectual displacement of these
proteins from chromatin probably
mediating this
synergistic effect so we thought well
what if we made a protac version
of these of of this molecule of these
molecules to induce
proteosomal degradation of cbt and p300
and how would that compare to inhibition
of the the bromidamine in
itself or the cat domain itself or the
two inhibitors combined and so we were
lucky in that we have a lot of choices
in order to
design a potential protac degrader of
these proteins um
we could choose to use either uh you
know a bromidamine ligand
um a varying potency that had been
developed by a number of different
groups here the most potent selective
being this
uh compound gne781 that was developed by
genentech
or we could use a half domain ligand or
a kappa main ligand um the most potent
at least the time when we started this
work was developed by abby
pharmaceuticals this molecule called
a4a5 which is
quite potent and a quite potent
inhibitor of the acetyl transferase
activity
um of these proteins and so while we had
a lot of choices we didn't have a lot of
bandwidth for with our chemistry so we
needed to make a decision as to which
molecule we were actually going to
make a protac version of and beyond just
what
compounds uh we would we would choose to
to
to link a solidimed-based um cerebellum
to greater two
uh where would we actually attach it on
the molecule
here where we here is where we did um
computational modeling
of the ternary complex of the e3 ligase
cerebellum bound actually to the bromide
domain or the
acetyl transferase domain of these
proteins and what we did was we
basically did
use this uh program program rosetta
docking um
which and and and doctors of the
bromonumeno the catholic thousands and
thousands of times against sarah won and
looked for
um minimal energy poses and just
basically measured
the distance between the different atoms
where we could potentially attach a
linker and
um the solidimized ligand in bound to
cerebellum
and what we found was and when we just
basically graphed the distribution of
the
of the distance between each of these
atoms and thalidomide
what we found was first that the
bromodomain
seemed to give us the most minimal
energy poses when compared to the acetyl
transferase domain
and when we looked at different
potential exit vectors for linker
attachment
within this gna 781 molecule it seemed
as this
this pyramid ring system would be would
basically give us the most sort of
minimal energy poses when docked into
serobot and so
that is the molecule that we um ended up
making here are some examples of some of
these poses of the bromarine here the
cvt bromine
docked into cerebellum you can see that
these poses specifically all have
linker potential linker distances under
20 angstroms
and so we designed this molecule
dcvp1 which has a four linkage
between here thalidomide which binds to
cerablot and
gne781 bound to uh
uh what was the pyramid ring system um
and this pig four linker has a
approximate distance of about 20
angstroms which um in theory would
allow for ternary complex formation of
all these different poses that we
that we predicted here um uh with this
linkage system
and so
and so to describe this molecule
in activity assays
we turned to the protein simple west as
tim highlighted um this was a machine
that i procured
basically as soon as i started my lab
because i knew we would be doing a lot
of
immunoblotting and amino acids and we
wanted to be able to
profile the activities of these
compounds and these classical compounds
very quickly
and so all of the blots that i'll show
you in
in these subsequent slides are actually
generated by the proteins of the west so
they're not technically western blots
but they're capillary amino acids
which actually worked quite well for cbt
and p300
these are very large proteins there's
300 kd
and so one of the real highlights and
real enabling features of using the
protein simple
system the west system for these
athletes was they were
allowed us to profile the activity of
dcp1 very rapidly
so in three hours we can go from lysate
to figuring out if this molecule worked
or not and
the molecule works quite uh quite
potently so you can see here's a dose
response activity of dcv21
uh degrading cvt you know at
concentrations less than 10 10 nanomolar
you can see within two hours of
treatment with the compound
we get almost complete degradation of
both cbp and p300 with dcvp1
um this activity can be rescued with
saturating doses of both free legal
free ligand of on the on the cbt and
p300 side the gne molecule
and pomalidomide on the uh as a e3 like
cerebellum ligand um this activity can
also be rescued
by blocking the proteasome or uh
nethulation of the
of the e3 complex itself this activity
is also
cerebral specific so in the cerebellum
knockout cell line we see
loss of the activity of tcp1
we also constructed a molecule um that
uh which we call dcbp
dcvp1 bump which actually abrogates its
binding
to cerebellum itself by adding a methyl
group on the
um on the right side of the molecule
here and you can see that
gcbd womp bump has no degradation
activity at all
see here we also have very selective
effective of of
cbp and p300 over brd2 brd3 and brd4
other bromine containing proteins so we
do not see well a degrader of these bet
proteins
is quite active here d-vet6 our dc-bb-1
compound does not degrade
uh any of these proteins so then we
wanted to address well
um what uh uh
we're a cancer biology lab and a cancer
epigenomics lab and so what cancers may
be most susceptible
to a degrader of cbp and p300 and so we
turn
to a crispr knockout data set developed
by the broad institute and the debt map
group over there where they've done
genome-wide crispr knockout screening
across
hundreds of cancer cell lines and we
just asked with the question well what
is what are the most
what are the cell lines uh and the tumor
types most sensitive to cbps p300
knockout and unambiguously
these were multiple myeloma cells you
can see here um
the dependency of multiple myeloma cell
lines
um here about 20 different cell lines
that are are dependent on on cbp and
here even more so on on t300
and so we thought this would be the best
um sort of first shot i go on to sort of
profiling dcbc one and it's activity in
a cancer model system
this is the the cell line mm-1s which i
mentioned before was hypersensitive to
the brd4
um ligands um you can see we also have
complete degradation of cbp and p300 at
doses less than 10 nanomolar here
and within two hours of treatment of
pcbp1
we see this observation across multiple
different
uh multiple myeloma cell lines mm-1r
kms12vm
kms34 um this molecule and growth
viability assays is quite potent
and significantly more potent than the
inhibitors of cbp and p300 either the
acetyl transferase inhibitors
or the bromidomain inhibitors and we see
that this activity is sort of
accentuated both in sort of an ic-50
shift
but also in a shift at e-max which is
likely
um uh indicative of us
of this molecule inducing
apoptosis in these cell lines in growth
over time acid we see that
tcbp1 this is a hundred nanomolar
treatment
can potently reduce cell numbers in
vitro
within 48 hours of treatment whereas
equimolar doses of the inhibitors
or even combination of the inhibitors
have a rather cytostatic effect at the
same dose
by profiling the transcriptome to try
and understand how this molecule is
working we can see that
dcbp1 treatment has a very distinct
effect on the multiple myeloma
transcriptone
we find that the gene that is most
downregulated because this is the cell
line where
the potent immunoglobulin enhancer is
translocated to the mikkochi gene
the mick gene is the most down regulated
gene of the entire
mm1s transcriptome with dcvp1 treatment
and this
mixed down regulation at the transcript
level is highly
um uh attenuated if you will
when compared to equimolar doses of
either at the
uh cat domain inhibitor or the bromine
inhibitor
or combinations of the hat and bromine
inhibitor
you can see at the protein level mech is
totally down regulated within six hours
of treatment
um we look at gene response signatures
by gene's enrichment analysis and we can
see that the mixed signature is the
problem is the
the most affected gene signature at the
transcript level
um with dcvp1 treatment when we look at
the proteome level
after three hours of treatment dc51 we
can see
specific down regulation of the target
cbp and p300 and also the
transcriptional target
mic we don't see significant uh down
regulation at the protein level again of
brd4
aylos which is the target of
pomalidomide and leadalinamide
binding to cerebellum and multiple
myeloma cells or also the known off
target
cereblum modulator gsp21
however at six hours you can see that a
vast amount of the proteome is affected
with pcbd1 treatment so
um i would encourage you if you use
dcvp1 or
or other cvp p300 graders in your
studies to focus on
early time points if you really want to
tease out the specific and acute effects
of cbt and p300
degradation at the epigenome level we
looked at
enhancer acetylation with k27
acetylation chip and we can see with
degradation of cvt and p300 that's
complete loss of lysine acetylation
at enhancer of the t300 and cbp binding
sites
shown here is that immunoglobulin locus
that drives nick expression and you can
see
here loss of acetylation with dcvp1
treatment where it's really only
modestly attenuated with
inhibitor treatment the chromatin
accessibility level with the taxi we see
that
enhancer with inhibition with the
inhibitors enhancers with the inhibitors
are largely
at least remain accessible whereas with
the
degrader we actually see loss of
chromatin accessibility which we think
is
loss of protein protein interaction
contexts that are mediated by cbt and
p300 leading to loss of transcription
factor engagement
with the enhancer itself um
and so we think that pcbp1 will be
a useful tool for understanding sort of
the
effects of cbp and p300 activity at
enhancers
um how they nucleate enhancer activity
and the acute effects of their depletion
on chromatin and we think it would be a
good
tool for teasing this out in cell
culture and in in vitro systems
um we also think that there's a
potential for tcbp
and ccvp1 or analog thereof or
other degraders of cbp and p300
potentially as
therapeutics for cancer you can imagine
the complete ablation of
enhancer of enhancers with uh with drugs
may not be therapeutically tolerable
um uh and so that's an area that we're
beginning to explore and we've done some
um here's some just some unpublished
work some recent work from the group
where we've actually been able to
establish
um some medieval activity of bcbd1 um
with daily dosing of dcvp1 at rather low
concentrations
um we can see uh by ip injection that
we actually don't have much effect on
the body mass of mice um that uh that
are injected with with dcvp1 um
so it seems to be well tolerated and
these are doses that
seem to be active so here we've
harvested four hours after
um the second dose of uh dcvp1
um we've harvested livers and we can
show you know
using the capillary system the amino
acid um
uh using the west system we can show uh
depletion
almost complete depletion in the liver
of cbt and p300 and yet this
seems to be well tolerated so um we
think that this
uh tool compound um can also have vivo
utility
um for studying pvp and p300 depletion
effects
um in vivo in mouse models
so with that i'll stop um i'd like to
particularly shout out
my group both current and past members
in particular rago vanim who led all of
the chemistry efforts for developing
uh dcvp one in my group um
and also i'd also like to shout out sam
ojeda in my group who led
all of the assays and and did all the
assays on the west system to profile
dcb1
treatment in the various cellular model
systems um i'd also like to particularly
shout out john segelian
in mike lawrence's lab who did all the
computational modeling
um and the folks in willie hospit lab
here at mgh who did all the proteomics
analysis of gcbp1 activity
and i think of course the support for
our lab from various funding sources
and i'm excited to take your questions
thank you very much
thank you dr ott and dr geiger for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started looks like we've
got some great questions
coming in from the audience already so
let's start with this one and dr ott
this is for you
is there a reason you decided to attach
the linker
to the five position of of uh the
uh thalidomide um as the four-point
as the floor position is more typically
seen in protects
um so when we did when we first did our
modeling studies of the the potential
ternary complex formation there was
some evidence that the the five position
carbon was slightly closer
um and so we made the decision to to do
the linkage off of that position now
you know i imagine that a four position
linked compound would
would work quite as well um uh would
also work
um so we don't have data that
comparative data between the two
linkages but um
that was the reason we just we made that
decision
great thank you so much so moving on to
our next quest
our next question so current protect
development
largely depends on empiric optimization
of the linker length
did you only synthesize the molecule
predicted by rosetta
to fit best or did you try several
linker lengths
yeah so um we made the decision up front
actually to use a peg for linker length
there have been
there's been a lot of protac based work
using a lot of different uh
liquor lengths and liquor compositions
and um
those are studies that we're pursuing
now and seeing how those can affect
um uh the the activity
of the molecules but um we made the
decision to make a peg four compound
because we thought that that would
it kind of hit a sweet spot in terms of
a potential for
degradation capability and then we made
the decision based on a peg four
linked molecule uh which um
uh based on the ternary complex modeling
which
sort of exit vector to attach the
molecule to in
the gme scaffold
wonderful thank you so much um we've got
a couple more questions so
now here actually here's a good one how
do you process the samples before
probing
for ep 300 on the wes right so we use
in our essays we use a typical ripple
buffer um and then we also
and then we followed by some incubation
on ice
and then we pass that um that lysate
through a fine gauge needle in order to
really
um do our best to comprehensively
disrupt the chromatin structures within
the lysate
we have also tried sonication of the uh
the lysates we found that sonicating the
samples led to a little bit more
variable results
um so we've been uh typically using a a
needle to pass this lysis
great thank you so much for that
clarification so
here's another question so how clean are
the digital westerns for
cbp p300 is there only a single peak
with used antibodies
or do you see multiple peaks at
different molecular weights
yeah we did a fair amount of
optimization on the west with with
a a variety of different antibodies we
found that um
these two antibodies from cell signaling
uh
did work the best in terms of
consistency of signal
in terms of how clean they are in terms
of um you know
the other bands and and the number of
bands that come up
this really depends on the cell type um
so some types some cell types will will
show you know multiple bands are sort of
a broad
um really broad range in the 300 kb
range
uh and some are quite quite clean in
terms of a single
um a single band
wonderful thank you so much uh we want
to remind our audience you know
any questions that we're unable to
answer today and those that come in
during the on-demand period will be
answered by our speakers
via the email address that you provided
at the time of registration so please
keep those questions coming in we're
happy to answer them all
um so dr geiger we haven't forgotten
about you i have a question for you
so how does the sensitivity of simple
western compare
with the western blood um
yeah that's that's a good question it
you know it's like with everything with
an amino acid kind of depends on the
performance of the antibody
but we've done quite a few studies on a
lot of different targets to try to
understand the sensitivity
um the the average
um seems to be around about fourfold
improvement relative to
a typical western blot but again it
depends on the target and there are some
targets where we see
significantly better sensitivity with
simple western compared to western blot
and um and uh
that's reflected in some of the papers
that have been published i can think of
one because it's someone i worked with
directly
as an fas a group out of cal state 410
that published a paper on on muscle
fibers where they were able to get
single fiber resolution of their targets
which had been struggled to achieve with
western blot
but because of uh working with the west
system um they were able to do that and
then doing so they were able to really
tease apart
um specific muscle fiber related um
signaling that
otherwise has been convoluted by the
fact that you always had to aggregate
um fibers able to do those studies so
that sensitivity can make a pretty big
difference
um in your in your work for sure
great thank you so much so dr aw we're
going to move um
excuse me we're going to move back over
to you how does the activity
of dcbp1 compare to other degraders
of uh remote bromodomain
proteins like dbets
yeah so um you know
we've spent we spent a lot of time
studying brd4 and the effects of bre4
inhibitors and
degraders on gene expression and
chromatin structures
um we haven't done much work comparing
you know the dc vp1 uh compound with the
dbet compounds
um we can imagine that you know the
activity of
of brd4 enhancers can be you know quite
similar to the activity of
cvp and p300 but also likely very
distinct um
brd4 has very specific relationships to
recruitment of ptfe
and activating elongation of the rna
polymerase complex
um and so we can imagine that you know
complete degradation of brd4 may have
very specific or
distinct effects than a degrader of cvt
and p300 and may lead to opportunities
potentially for
synergistic activity on enhancers and
and promoters together
but we have not uh as of yet done
comprehensive head-to-head analysis on
of the two compound series
great thank you so we do have time for a
couple more questions so
dr geiger we'll move back over to you um
what data do you typically see people
report out
um electro for it uh excuse me
electro for ferrograms or that western
blot style view
uh yeah i guess it kind of depends on
personal preference
um i think what i've seen mostly is
uh when people are internally analyzing
their data
they quickly become acquainted with that
electro-ferrogram view
uh it's it's truly sort of the
quantitative way to look at your data
and so as you get more familiar with it
you'll you'll find
that you really see a value in that way
of reporting out the data
in terms of just the power to be able to
uh quantitate it
visualize it understand any kind of like
variability and stuff like that
um the disadvantage of it of course is
just that there's uh
it's difficult to put a lot of data in a
single small space uh the
classic western block quote unquote view
um gives you that power
and that's the reason like when i was
reporting my data out and talking about
quantitation i was showing you guys
electric fairgrounds but then when
dr ott was showing his data where he has
a large number of samples that he wants
to show in a single
single slide uh it's advantageous to
throw up that uh blot for you
um so a lot of times with papers we do
see that people use the blot view
just to be able to encapsulate the
information in the small space
but when you're looking at your own data
you'll you'll find very quickly
that you're going to really prefer and
appreciate that electroparagram view
great thank you so much um back over to
you dr ott
how's your work with dcpv1 or analog
shown any selective degradation for cbp
or p300 over the other
yeah that's a great question um so yeah
obviously it would be
fantastic to be able to develop even
more selective tools for one versus the
other
um and the answer is yes we do see um
certain contexts and and some analogs
that actually show
selectivity of one versus the other
we're trying to understand the um
molecular recognition events that that
mediate that seal activity
um and so we're actually working on that
now
wonderful thank you and how about did
they alter the heat
denaturing step for the west samples
i believe that's probably a question for
us um uh
no we did not we did not alter any
um denaturing steps
great thank you so much okay um
looks like we've got time for maybe one
or two more questions so
dr uh what is the optimal dose and time
point
i should use dcvp1 in my cell system
in order to study direct effects of p300
cbp loss yeah another good question so i
think
um typically in most
cell systems we see almost complete
at least by os analysis complete
degradation
uh of both cbp and p300 within
uh you know two to two to three hours of
treatment
at about 100 nanomolar so i think that's
a good um
dose and time point to start um but with
any cell system you'll want to
tune it based on yourself your your cell
type
we have noticed some cell types um where
uptake of the molecule is slightly
attenuated so
the dynamics take a little bit longer in
order to
uh to cause degradation um but you'll
want to be careful
in terms of doing analysis at longer
time points because
you know we've noticed by proteomics
analysis that in some cell lines
you know at six hours you see massive
effects on the proteome beyond just cbt
and p300 so if you're looking to measure
you know sort of acute primary effects
of the loss of cvp and p300 you'll want
to keep
the time points short and sort of tune
it based on your cell system
wonderful thank you so much um so here's
another question so for the immunoblot
of cbp
and p300 did you do multiplexing with
insulin and gap dh
and which one do you recommend for
multiplexing
with cbp p300 and simple western
yeah so we typically multiplex with
zinculin because we use the high
molecular weight kit
um and vinculin as a as a as a
higher molecular weight that we could um
uh that we could assay together with cbp
and p300 together so yeah we just mixed
the antibodies together
um and and and random in a multiplex
fashion
great thank you so much okay so it looks
like we've got time for maybe one more
question
so um you know what dr we'll go ahead
and end with you
so for your modeling efforts to design
uh dcbp1 did you incorporate
confirmations of various linker
structures
uh we didn't um we actually tried to
keep it simple
um we know that you know there have been
other groups that have
used the rosetta modeling package and
and
different types of protein complex
modeling to actually model
linker conformations to really design
try and
you know anticipate what linker design
may be
maybe optimal uh we didn't do that we're
trying a little bit of that now but
we simply just made made measurements
between
the two ligands on their respective
proteins and then um
you know sort of you know analyze the
distribution of those
of the direct um uh lengths between
between the two uh the two ligands um
we can imagine that you know in some
cases they might that might not work
perfectly there might be steric
um issues with with residues blocking
that
that that proposed linker um uh
or that proposed avenue if you will um
uh but in this case we by manual
inspection we didn't see
any um uh
docking that would that would predict
that so um we kept it simple and just
went with
uh the straight distance between the two
great thank you so much before we go i'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today
and for their interesting questions
questions that we did not have time for
today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr ott
and dr geiger for hit for their time
today
and their important research we would
also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor biotechny for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
to share with your friends and
colleagues that's all for now
thank you for joining us and have a
great rest of your day everyone
bye